it's now time for our seen and unseen
segment where we explore some of the big
cultural stories of the day
now in a moment we'll dive into
political American Music Awards but
first last Friday segment with Raymond
Arroyo went viral made international
headlines we call it fall Gate it became
a social media debate was it an accident
or is it a comedy bit for answers we're
joined by Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor and New York Times
bestselling author the will while their
series Raymond you'd what this is
ridiculous this we're talking about it
ambulance chaser lawyers out there I'm
glad I have this moment because I want
people to know the reality and the truth
of this guy
tens of millions of people watched this
viral video they saw what happened those
two gentlemen over there who you haven't
met that's mr. Biddle and mister
Billingsworth
those are my attorneys you'll meet them
after the show I want you I'm going to
show the audience the ever that the
video of what happened last week now I
want you to keep your eye on Laura
Ingram's right hand watch what happens
roll the tape smile do we have it the
ACLU used to care about the rights of
accused you threw me down in such a
cruel fashion heartless my hand slipped
a little bit me with great vigor I saw
it I'm gonna slap you with a parole
guards or employee injury what do I take
before injured they're gonna take fifty
percent your kids will be play paying my
personal injury claim when I'm done okay
everybody saw this including James
Corden who tweeted out I can't stop
watching this members of the audience
they saw it all to one said oh my god
are you okay Ingraham angle someone let
us know please then another viewer oh my
god I freaked out and laugh I'm sorry
but it was funny and at the same time I
was going holy hmm I hope it was fake
well not we can tell the truth floor
well how long have you been cooking up
this first of all that that brace you
while I get CV
an hour ago where it was not expensing
that either this was not this was not
fake but it was staged if people were
watching the segment we we had the
segment on dangerous selfies and these
other protests at the beginning we were
just entertaining people I mean people
like oh so cold the spot I was trying to
stop myself from laughing but you did
see the video what evidence I mean it
was are you okay
I'm getting better